This point you're probably
sick of matrix multiply, but
I can't say enough what an important
computational primitive it is to study.
Now I say that, not only because I
think it has important applications,
it's also because you can use it to see
a lot of different analysis techniques.
For instance, in this lesson you saw
different algorithmic approaches
like 1-D versus 2-D
versus 3-D distributions.
As well as a way to argue about
communication lower bounds.
It won't always be easy to do those
sorts of analyses on other algorithms,
but I hope you'll try.
Another reason to think about matrix
multiply is that for better or for
worse, the machines we build today,
if you're a wee bit cynical like me,
are tuned for it.
For instance,
you should have noticed something.
When the problem is big enough, there's
a lot more work than communication.
That means matrix multiply ought
to scale well as systems and
problems get bigger.
It's in that sense that things like
the top 500 list, which measure peak
capability, might not translate to more
communication-intensive applications.
Now speaking of big, and I admit this
fact as a bit of a non sequitur.
Did you know that a Rubix cube has
43 quintillion 252 quadrillion 3
trillion 274 billion 489 million 856
thousand possible configurations?
Try telling people that fact at
your next cocktail party, and
I'm sure you'll be a really big hit.
Just like me, because I'm a huge hit
at cocktail parties with my numbers and
my constants out to ten digits and
stuff.
Very cool.